Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Buongiorno.
Buongiorno a tutti, buongiorno.
Lo dico più volte
perché siete veramente in tanti,
è un bell'effetto che fa,
essere qua sopra.
Parleremo di un qualcosa
che è estremamente dibattuto,
è stato dibattuto da persone
decisamente più interessanti di me,
e con cultura maggiore.
Lo cercheremo di fare in un modo diverso,
con una prospettiva diversa,
cercando di farvi entrare
all'interno della nostra prospettiva,
che è quella di dover prendere decisioni
in frazioni di secondo.
È più o meno il tema
di questa giornata, "Zero":
zero secondi è quello che dev'essere
il nostro modo di prendere decisioni.
Quasi istintivo, quasi una cosa meccanica.
E siccome ho degli amici
molto carini a TED,
io sono abituato a fare delle partite
che durano tendenzialmente 90 minuti,
mi hanno detto: "Tu hai solo
15 minuti di tempo
per poter fare
questa breve presentazione".
15 minuti di tempo è per me
un fattore di pressione, non semplice;
per voi, una garanzia che almeno
non vi annoierò più di 15 minuti.
Ci sono due cose, in Italia,
[che] davanti a una platea,
non bisogna mai fare:
parlare di politica - difficile;
l'altra è parlare di calcio.
Riuscire a parlare di calcio con voi,
quando noi siamo l'unica squadra al mondo
che non ha tifosi - anzi, di solito
siamo bersagliati, dai tifosi -
di per sé anche questo
mette un pochettino sotto pressione.
Ed è per questo che voglio partire
un pochettino da lontano.
Avevo 13 anni quando ho deciso di fare...
l'architetto.
(Risate)
Ho sempre avuto questa passione:
in realtà ho scelto a 13 anni
perché sono entrato nella cartoleria,
ho visto luci, colori, penne, i fogli,
l'odore del foglio, l'odore della gomma.
Ricordate quando entravate
in una cartoleria,
e c'era ancora l'odore della gomma?
Lì ho deciso: io voglio fare l'architetto.
Il mio percorso,
la mia carriera formativa,
sarà per fare architettura da grande.
Volevo imparare
le regole dell'architettura
per mettere in difficoltà gli ingegneri.
Sapete che gli architetti
vogliono sempre costruire
qualcosa di strano?
Costruire degli spazi che poi dopo dici:
ma come fanno a stare su?
Gli ingegneri ti dicono: e la struttura?
La struttura non è importante,
perché per noi la cosa
più importante del mondo
è regalare emozioni
e trasmettere emozioni.
Il mio obiettivo era far modo
che una persona entrasse nello spazio,
e dicesse "Wow!" oppure "Brr!".
Però era comunque un'emozione,
lasciare un segno
e far qualcosa per le persone che,
nel momento in cui entravano dentro,
dicevano "Bello!".
Io ero molto ambizioso,
e il mio obiettivo era lasciare un segno
nell'architettura italiana.
E ovviamente, è per questo
che faccio l'arbitro.
(Risate)
Però questo dualismo
tra la figura dell'arbitro
e la figura dell'architetto
mi è sempre rimasta abbastanza dentro
nel cuore, nel mio Dna.
Da una parte c'era
la volontà di conoscere,
di imparare il più possibile;
dall'altro, far rispettare
le regole che avevo imparato.
È un binomio che
tendenzialmente è in antitesi,
però nel mio caso è andata
abbastanza di comune accordo.
Da una parte volevo creare spazi, luoghi;
dall'altra volevo controllare
gli stessi luoghi e gli stessi spazi.
Essenzialmente, il mio obiettivo
era creare e controllare emozioni.
Da una parte una cosa molto rigida;
dall'altra, una cosa
molto più dinamica e divertente.
Questo controllare le emozioni
era un modo, anche,
per poterle vivere, farle vivere;
e allo stesso tempo,
l'obiettivo principale di un arbitro
è cercare di gestire le emozioni.
Questo binomio immediatamente,
sin da piccolo,
quando io a 15 anni ho deciso
di fare l'arbitro di calcio -
e ci vuole veramente
una forma mentis particolare,
perché non so per quale motivo
e non mi sono ancora dato
una risposta del perché l'ho fatto.
Però ti mette di fronte
a delle realtà molto particolari.
Questa fotografia rappresenta benissimo
quella che è la mia
prima parte della carriera.
Da una parte architettonica,
perché solo un architetto
può fare un campo
in un'isola, in cose
come questa, molto particolari.
Dall'altra parte,
la solitudine dell'arbitro.
L'arbitro è una persona
che è abituata a parlare da solo in campo.
Mettetevi all'interno di un campo,
22 persone, 21 persone
che seguono un pallone,
corrono dietro a un pallone,
e tu corri dietro a 22 persone
che inseguono un pallone.
È una cosa già di per sé
abbastanza particolare.
Devi trovare un modo
per gestire anche i tempi morti,
perché all'inizio c'erano
tantissimi tempi morti.
Mi ricordo che, quando ho dovuto decidere,
ero in difficoltà alla prima partita
per un fallo laterale.
Fallo laterale voleva dire:
la palla è uscita;
è stata toccata per ultimo
dal giocatore blu;
il giocatore blu attacca
in quella direzione;
io indico di là.
E diventa anche questo un micro-meccanismo
che doveva avere una razionalità dietro.
E il tutto ho capito subito
che mi creava tensione,
e per questo io cantavo
durante le partite.
Nel tempo, ovviamente,
aumentando la difficoltà delle partite,
queste canzoni sono diventate
parole, e domande:
più domande mi facevo,
più mi davo risposte.
Fino a che, pian pianino,
non mi sono trovato nelle partite
un pelo più complicate,
quelle che mi hanno creato
i primi problemi,
quelli che hanno cambiato
il mio approccio alla partita.
Ve la descrivo brevemente:
questo è un esempio
successo davvero, peraltro.
Avevo 20 anni,
mi trovavo la domenica a dover andare
a Berceto, provincia di Parma,
quando il sabato sera tutti i miei amici
erano andati al mare,
o in discoteca, a divertirsi.
Passione, sacrificio - difficile.
Mi ritrovo in questa partita
dove c'era pioggia, freddo, tanto freddo.
Situazioni difficili in campo,
giocatori che protestavano,
pubblico che mi insultava
dal primo minuto,
ancor prima che iniziassimo
a scendere in campo,
la tensione che bloccava le gambe -
e probabilmente anche il fango,
perché sapete, quando la scarpa
è nel fango fai fatica a muoverla.
Non so se era il fango o la tensione.
Finisce il primo tempo tra gli insulti,
perché c'era una richiesta di rigore;
allontanato l'allenatore;
situazioni difficili.
Non vedo l'ora di entrare in spogliatoio,
chiudere la porta e dire:
"Ma chi me l'ha fatto fare?"
Che è la domanda peggiore
che uno si possa fare,
nel momento in cui
sta facendo il proprio lavoro:
vuol dire che è fuori contesto,
in quel momento.
Freddo: io ho sempre sofferto
il freddo da morire.
In quella partita ho detto:
io smetto, io prendo,
vado a casa, non torno -
non faccio neanche
il secondo tempo: smetto.
E invece qualcosa è scattato,
qualcosa della volontà di reagire,
la volontà di andare oltre all'ostacolo.
"Io non mollo mai",
[mi sono detto] dentro di me.
Mi sono tolto la maglietta,
avevo solo una maglietta di ricambio.
Ovviamente, sbagliando,
avevo preso quella a maniche corte.
Bene, vado in campo, decido
di non sentire il freddo, di divertirmi,
di guardare il gioco
e di vivere le cose in maniera diversa.
Incomincia il secondo tempo:
non sento il freddo.
A maniche corte, non sento freddo.
Mi rendo conto, dopo pochi minuti,
che non sento il freddo,
non sento la pioggia.
Aveva smesso di piovere, peraltro,
quindi forse anche per quello.
(Risate)
Però mi rendo conto che la concentrazione,
l'approccio e il modo di vedere le cose
cambiavano quello che era
il mio sentimento.
E allora ho capito
che ci sono delle emozioni
che purtroppo influivano tantissimo
sul mio modo di essere.
C'era una parte di stress
che influiva tantissimo
su quello che era il mio modo di essere.
Imparare questa cosa è un pochettino
anche mettersi a confronto con le persone
che di solito ci criticano.
Tutti quelli che ci offendevano,
o comunque vedono l'arbitro
sempre come un nemico,
e noi non siamo nemici,
non capiscono una cosa fondamentale.
Questo è un proverbio spagnolo, che dice:
"Non è la stessa cosa parlare di tori
che essere nell'arena".
Essere nell'arena è diverso.
Nell'arena c'è lo stress,
che incide tantissimo
su tutto quello che fate,
sul vostro modo di vedere le cose,
sulle vostre emozioni,
che influiscono sulle vostre decisioni;
e soprattutto sul vostro modo di reagire.
Quindi mi sono deciso di fare
un qualcosa per me stesso,
di studiarmi, conoscermi,
conoscere anche le dinamiche di gioco
per poter prepararmi in maniera adeguata.
Questa è una partita di calcio.
Oddio, simile: però,
provate a fare un paragone.
La partita di calcio,
ovviamente ad alti livelli,
è come se fosse un'equazione
di 100 variabili, con 100 variabili,
e voi dovete risolverla
in un minuto: impossibile.
L'obiettivo di un arbitro
è esattamente il contrario:
risolvere tutto prima di vederlo.
Se noi su 100 variabili ne conosciamo,
prima di scendere in campo, 50,
l'equazione è più semplice.
Se di queste 50, appena comincia
la partita, ne capiamo altre 20,
diventa tutto molto più semplice.
Questo è il nostro obiettivo:
conoscere per prevedere,
e prevedere vuol dire
riuscire a fare le cose meglio
senza incappare nell'errore.
A questo punto, la domanda
che mi fanno più spesso di tutti è:
quanto coraggio ci vuole
a scendere in campo,
a prendere una decisione,
a fischiare un rigore
magari in una finale di Champions League.
Come ho fatto, e ho fatto senza avere
tutti gli elementi per valutare:
dinamiche di gioco;
conoscenza dei giocatori; esperienza -
tutta una serie di variabili
che sono riuscito a preparare
prima dell'evento.
Quanto coraggio ci vuole?
Zero.
La decisione non è mai
una questione di coraggio.
Il coraggio ci vuole
nel pre-partita, quello sì:
l'ansia, l'attesa, la prestazione.
Quella è una questione di coraggio,
di gestione delle emozioni.
In realtà, il coraggio
non c'entra nulla sulla decisione.
La decisione è solo frutto
di aver fatto una procedura corretta.
Quando noi, a casa, abbiamo fatto
di tutto per prepararci,
conoscere i giocatori mentalmente,
atleticamente e fisicamente in campo,
abbiamo fatto di tutto per scegliere
la prospettiva migliore,
perché per noi è fondamentale.
Dopo la decisione è una conseguenza,
e delle volte può anche essere sbagliata.
Questo ti dà la forza
di superare anche gli errori.
Allora, qual è la cosa
che definiamo il "nemico" dell'arbitro?
È una cosa un po' particolare:
quello che a noi ci frega, di solito,
è l'effetto sorpresa.
Tutti voi dite, di solito,
"Non me l'aspettavo, non ero preparato,
è una cosa sopraggiunta all'improvviso":
l'effetto sorpresa è quello
che non puoi prevedere.
Allora, a questo punto,
è una questione di capacità.
Capacità di agire vuol dire prevedere
e riuscire a fare le cose,
reagire nel momento
in cui siamo sorpresi: l'istinto.
L'obiettivo di un arbitro
è fare in modo che l'istinto
diventi una cosa razionale, meccanica.
Vi faccio un esempio:
c'è qualcuno che sta guidando,
buca una gomma in autostrada,
a 160 chilometri all'ora.
Questa persona - d'istinto, di capacità,
o comunque di esperienza -
magari riesce a controllare
la macchina e parcheggiare:
un'altra persona scoppia la gomma -
stessa situazione - va a sbattere.
È istinto, ma un istinto
si può comunque razionalizzare,
e far sì che ci sia all'interno,
alle spalle di questo,
un ragionamento meccanico e istintivo.
Questo è il nostro obiettivo.
Vi faccio un esempio
per farvi capire un pochettino meglio
quello che è capitato,
l'esperienza con cui ho imparato,
nel tempo, le varie situazioni.
Quarti di finale di Champions League.
Atletico Madrid - Barcellona:
è una delle partite più delicate.
L'andata era finita 2-1 per il Barcellona,
quindi c'era la possibilità di ribaltare,
di fare, eccetera: partita difficile.
Giocatori - molti li conoscete,
magari chi di voi
gioca a calcio li conosce.
Gli allenatori estremamente
difficili da arbitrare.
Io ho fatto la partita
migliore della mia vita.
La migliore della mia vita...
fino ai minuti di recupero.
Nei minuti di recupero,
dopo che ho preso tante decisioni,
e avevo dato anche un rigore, giustamente,
ai minuti di recupero
c'è una situazione particolare,
che io vedo, controllo -
ma mancavano veramente dieci secondi.
Fallo di mano di un giocatore chiaro,
messo in posizione bene.
Fischio: dal fallo di mano guardo i piedi,
i piedi sono fuori
dall'area di tanto così.
Fuori area.
Proteste, non proteste.
Dopo due minuti la partita finisce,
vado negli spogliatoi,
arriva l'osservatore,
che abbiamo in tutte le partite,
e mi dice: "Purtroppo era dentro".
Oggi, a proposito di quello
che dicevamo prima,
in un secondo, con la VAR
la tecnologia mi direbbe che era dentro.
L'errore più grosso della mia vita
l'ho fatto nel momento in cui ero convinto
di aver finito la partita,
nel momento in cui
sembrava tutto perfetto.
Noi viviamo, purtroppo,
all'interno di un corridoio
dove tutto sembra perfetto.
Voi considerate questo come un corridoio
paragonabile a una partita di calcio.
300 situazioni, 300 camere dell'albergo
nelle quali dovete aprire la porta,
guardare, valutare, prendere decisioni
e chiudere la porta.
Detta così sembra facile:
l'albergo è anche bellino, peraltro.
Mettiamoci un po' di pressione.
Paragoniamolo al corridoio di Shining,
ci mettiamo davanti
il bambino col triciclo,
e questa bambino è il tempo:
voi dovete seguire il bambino
che andrà più veloce, più lentamente.
Questo è il tempo della partita.
E dovete prendere tutte le decisioni
con la velocità con cui
il bambino va avanti.
Si può fare, indubbiamente si può fare.
300 situazioni di cui: 150 quasi nulle;
50 riguardano il fuorigioco;
una cinquantina di calci d'angolo,
falli laterali eccetera;
30 sono quelle che voi fischiate,
i falli che decidete di punire.
Di questi 30, uno cambia la partita.
E se fate un errore,
dietro c'è Jack Nicholson col coltello
che non vede l'ora
di mettervelo nella schiena.
Questa è un pochettino la partita:
300 situazioni, all'interno
delle quali dovete sapere
che dalla prima all'ultima [Jack]
non vede l'ora di mettere il coltello.
E Jack Nicholson rappresenta
i tifosi, i massmedia,
tutti quelli che ovviamente odiano
le persone che prendono decisioni.
Nessuno di loro ha mai capito
che noi in realtà siamo persone normali.
Allora?
Calma.
Ci sono momenti in cui è troppo.
La nostra preparazione ci chiede troppo:
controllo di qua, controllo di là.
Ripartiamo.
Controlla ciò che puoi.
Controlla ciò che puoi
è un po' il mio mantra:
quando facevo delle partite
che erano troppo impegnative
e mi rendevo conto
che la tensione rischiava
di essere un po' eccessiva,
cercavo di riportare il tutto
al livello proporzionato.
Il controllo, poi,
è una cosa molto importante:
allora oggi, siccome ho parlato
di quelle che sono
le difficoltà dell'arbitraggio,
vorrei fare un gioco con voi.
Chi lo vuole fare:
chi non lo vuole fare
può benissimo non farlo.
Però vorrei portarvi all'interno
dell'unico momento
divertente di un arbitro,
che è il pre-partita, l'ingresso in campo.
Il momento più bello dell'arbitro
è quando l'arbitro prende il pallone:
io di solito lo baciavo
per sentire prima di tutto l'odore,
che mi ricordava quando ero bambino,
che accudivo il pallone,
lo rotolavo fra le mani, sentivo l'odore.
E vi voglio portare con me
in questa esperienza:
quindi, se abbassiamo le luci,
chi lo vuole fare chiude gli occhi,
ascolta la mia voce
e li riaprirà nel momento
in cui sente i tifosi.
Siamo in Brasile, stadio Maracanà,
che solo il nome credo
che rappresenti la storia -
credo che tutti voi conosciate
il modo di giocare dei brasiliani,
il divertimento dei brasiliani
nel giocare a calcio.
Siete all'interno dello spogliatoio.
State salutando i vostri colleghi,
gli assistenti, e gli dite: "Divertitevi",
perché la cosa più importante,
quando scendiamo in campo, è divertirsi.
Aprite lo spogliatoio,
vi dirigente verso il tunnel
e ci sono schierate le due formazioni:
Germania, lato sinistro,
e Argentina lato destro.
Stanno per scendere in campo
per giocarsi la finale
della Coppa del Mondo.
Voi guardate Lam alla vostra sinistra,
e gli dite "Good Luck!",
e lui vi dà la mano.
Alla vostra destra c'è Messi:
gli stringete la mano, gli dite "Suerte".
E vi rendete conto
che loro sono talmente assenti,
talmente concentrati
su quello che è il loro obiettivo:
vincere quella maledetta,
piccolina Coppa del Mondo
che in quel momento,
nonostante sia alta 20 centimetri,
rappresenta il centro dell'universo.
Tutto il mondo sta guardando
questa partita.
Loro non rappresentano loro stessi:
loro rappresentano una nazione, un popolo.
Per l'Argentina, addirittura,
vincere la Coppa del Mondo in Brasile
sarebbe una cosa grandiosa, strepitosa.
Guardate avanti anche voi:
davanti alla Coppa del Mondo
c'è il pallone che tra poco
prenderete in mano.
E rotolerà sul campo del Maracanà.
(Video)
Divertitevi, sempre.
Grazie.
(Applausi)